many upcoming high-profile films have
already scheduled their debuts and some
have even released trailers to the
public at large unfortunately some of
them also look pretty lame you heard it
here first
these are fated to be the worst movies
of 2019 all the most popular stage
musicals eventually get adapted into
films they're well known enough for
studios to take a chance on them they
almost always score an Oscar nom or two
and they give musical fans who don't
live in New York a rare chance to enjoy
them in 2019 another well-known musical
will hit movie screens and no sadly it's
not Hamilton it's cats debuting on
Broadway in 1982 Katz is a loosely
plotted show based on a book of poetry
by TS Eliot which is about well cats
singing dancing frolicking homeless cats
cats his original run ended in 2000 and
Hollywood has finally figured out a way
to do this show but not via animation
like you might expect no it seems the
stars of the movie who include Taylor
Swift Ian McKellen Jennifer Hudson and
James Corden are going to actually dress
up in cat costumes so does this have any
prayer of being the next musical to
clean up at the Oscars not meow
not ever it just wouldn't be a New Year
without another movie in which an angry
Liam Neeson tracks and kills a small
army of bad guys who did him wrong
following the three taken movies run all
night the commuter and many many more
comes cold pursuit
this time Neeson shows off his very
particular set of skills as a
mild-mannered rocky mountain snow plow
driver named Nelson who is forced into
action when his son is killed by a drug
cartel
unfortunately Neeson has done the same
movie so many times that it's starting
to get a little embarrassing why would I
do it
because there would be a reward
one thing in cold pursuits favor however
is that it's based on a pretty good
Norwegian dark comedy called in order of
disappearance it's just a shame they
seem to have drained all the humor out
of it in the beachbum the always cool
and totally chill Matthew McConaughey
plays a beach loving stoner named moon
dog and no despite what you might
remember this movie doesn't already
exist maybe you're thinking of surfer
dude while the title and details make it
sound like a straight-to-video National
Lampoon branded boorish comedy from the
early 90s it's actually an indie movie
albeit one directed by Harmony Korine
mostly known for more unsettling
projects such as kids and Gummo at least
the cast is likable Zac Efron plays a
dude named flicker Snoop Dogg portrays
someone genuinely named lingerie and
Martin Lawrence makes an appearance as
Captain whack role on awards season the
Rambo movies may hold claim to the film
franchise that has feared the furthest
from its original intent the first entry
in the series first blood was the
harrowing and tragic story of a PTSD
stricken Vietnam War veteran starring
Sylvester Stallone in what was probably
his finest and most nuanced work since
the original Rocky
then came the second one and everything
changed war won't stop a First Blood
Part two it will escalate to Rambo 3
which should really be called rainbow 2
First Blood Part 3 but the Rambo titles
never made sense the political climate
of the 1980s fueled an explosion of
action movies that celebrated American
patriotism and hardcore violence and so
the subsequent first blood sequels had
the same broken man become a
muscle-bound machine gun wielding
one-man army who routinely shoots up
entire villages full of terrorists live
for nothing
but for something Stallone's career has
been reinvigorated in recent years
thanks to the success of old-school
action franchise The Expendables as well
as his Oscar nomination for the role of
Rocky Balboa and Creed as part of this
victory lap Stallone has decided to go
and make the completely unnecessary
Rambo 5 this time Rambo faces off
against the drug cartel odds are he'll
come out on top which is an impressive
feat considering both Stallone and his
character are well over 70 years old the
rhythm section is pretty much exactly
like peppermint 2008 teens moderately
successful taken rip-off starring
Jennifer Garner
this one stars Gossip Girl veteran Blake
Lively at Stefanie Patrick a woman who
slowly and methodically tracks down a
bunch of bad guys because she just knows
they're responsible for the plane crash
that killed her family Lively is no
stranger to an action thriller having
starred in 2016's the shallows but it's
hard to get worked up about this and the
best part it's based on a book series so
you can probably count on a sequel or
six somewhere down the line
[Music]